[Music]
I will be showing you one of my games I
played recently at the World Team
Championship in Turkey and it was a it
was a really good tournament for me I
won individual gold medal on my board
and US team did pretty well I think
overall we had some really big win
against Russia we won against Russia
again so two in a row and unfortunately
finish fourth just a little bit behind
winning a medal as a team but I had a
very good performance and the gold medal
on my board so this game I'm playing
with the white pieces against an
international master from Egypt and I
play d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 so Knight c3
Bishop b4 so nimzo-indian defense
opening and it was very interesting the
first three games I played I got
dispositions with white so I had like
three the first few games I played I
just people just kept on playing this
nimzo-indian against me and I had two
draws against very strong players but
now I had a chance to try to win with
white so I played Quincy - this is the
main move in this position the other
popular option is to play III the
Rubinstein variation Queen c2 is the
classical setup and now my opponent
played castle
I played a three Bishop takes c3 Queen
c3 and here of course I was you know
well prepared against the mainlines p6 d
5 here 94 for example but then he makes
a move that I've actually seen before
but it's such a rare move that you're
not really gonna leave all the main
lines and sub variations to start
looking at this move here so didn't have
much preparation against this move
Queenie 8
so the question is why is he playing
this move what is he trying to do now by
moving his Queen and simps bid add this
move because the pieces are not
developed but who can tell me the idea
behind it he's well II five not quite
not quite he 5 e 5 if you go he can just
take there is another idea here try to
see if you can see what is it really
trying to do by going queenie 8 years
aha aha yes that's what he is trying to
do that's his idea he wants to get the
night only for in some point and play at
5 and then his queen wouldn't be that
bad he can jump in on g6 but what else
is he stopping
what else is he stopping here that is
very important yes
no what is black trying to stop yeah I
mean he can't go to key it now but he's
not too worried about that here yes
black is always trying to stop before
here that's the main idea in the names
of Indian to stop before Bishop g5 and
that's what I wanted you to say because
in these positions the main move is
usually Bishop g5 and creating the pin
but when he moves the Queen away
now you go Bishop g5 he is gonna go 94
with the tempo because the Queen is no
longer pinned on the 8th ok so that's
why he's playing the move Queen eh Queen
e8 has been played by some very strong
players about maybe 40 to 45 games in a
database one of the top players is the
indian grandmaster hari krishna who
played this move so at first i swear i
was like what is this and then you know
it was like few years ago and then
suddenly somebody is actually playing
this move against me but what to do when
you're surprised in the opening when
your opponent makes a surprising move
what you should do is urine you still
have to just try to make logical moves
don't try to think oh I have to punish
him because he's making a suspicion try
to make logical moves in this position
yes AHA ef3 to play for excellent that's
what I played f3 in the nimzo-indian
defence it's a bottle block is trying to
control the e4 square and put a 924 and
play a 5 and white is trying to do the
opposite he wants to control the e4
square
so usually who'd have whoever can
succeed in this battle on the e4 square
will probably have the advantage exactly
so my opponent played d6 when you give
up the dark square bishop you don't want
to play d5 anymore because that will be
a bad idea because your dark squares are
already weak so you should try to keep
the pawns on a dark square to sort of
compensate that so your darks words are
not too weak if you play d5 now I go
Bishop f4 and it's just the good
position so he played these six now now
I had a choice here what to do efore or
Bishop g5 so of course I played III I
want to control e4 but still I had to
work work a little bit here too to
realize which move is actually the best
here what do you think which move I
played
aha explain why Bishop g5 is better than
e4 make sense Bishop g5 was played this
is a move that actually gaining a tempo
everybody know here what is tempo tempo
is when you make a move creating a sort
of a threat or attacking something in
making the opponent to react to your
move so here I make this move he needs
to do something because he doesn't want
me to take the knight on f6 and double
his pants and expose the position of the
king so you develop a piece with the
tempo and that's what you want to do in
the opening now he played another
unusual move of course 9b d7 was a
natural move but then he didn't like to
be under this pressure with Bishop f6 so
that's why he played Knight f d7 this
came as a little bit of a surprise
actually I didn't quite expect that him
he will play this move now I decided
again I had a choice here to play before
it's very tempting here but I decided to
castle first so I Castle first and it's
gonna be very sharp here because he's
gonna start pushing his pants on the
Queen side and I'm gonna try to attack
his King on the g8 but after two
consecutive draws in the tournament even
though against strong players 2700
players I had I drew feeder I wanted to
play aggressive and I didn't want to
have like this long kind of endgame type
position so I wanted to see if I can
just attack him and try to win the game
in an attacking style now he plays a5
gaining space and in some point he wants
to play a four
now the next move what should Y do here
it's time to play which move here we
have been delaying that move for a
little bit right we have been delaying
it for a little bit but after the
development after the safety of the king
it's time to do it yes II for
controlling the center yes now look at
that Center now if I can get a couple of
more moves in here develop my bishop and
a knight white will have small advantage
or a big advantage you think if I
managed to develop my pieces the night
in a bishop here with a big center and a
pair of the bishops this could be
actually a big advantage not just a
small advantage so that's why he's
trying to do something so he plays d5
he's trying to get that c5 square for
the knight and the question is what
should I do
how should I react to this move e5
should I keep the tension should I
exchange should I advance my pawn let me
give you a little bit of time here to
see if you can find the best move here
white to play what should I do here
there are a few options here
d5 the natural move to play but in a
previous lecture we talked about lecture
before this when a player has two
knights he's aiming to keep the position
closed right when the other player has
two bishops he is trying to open the
position so here if we play d5 you gain
space but then you give up the c5 square
and position is going to be really
closed and that will be actually
advantageous for black so we don't
necessarily want to play d5 here yet I
know I can take the pawn but if I take
then I feel like a little bit worried
about this square
because he could have some potential
ideas of jumping in on D for his
knocking go here and black is doing okay
here Black is fine
92 aha yes your question 92 aha
92 is the correct move to keep the
tension okay because you develop a piece
and you keep the tension even if it
takes now you take back with the night
and you have a strong knight on d4 he
goes Knight to c6
now it was night to see six now aha
very good see again I'm not trying
actually yeah I think he played he
played a for first story he played a for
first and here I play G for because
that's what I mentioned right he when we
go opposite color opposite side castling
we start advancing the pawns g4 and h4
so now Knight to c6 h-12 now he plays he
takes d4 Knight XD 490 XD for Queen
takes d4 and he plays Knight to c5
threatening a very very strong fork
so now you need to make a move to avoid
that fork and make sure the king is
still remaining safe King be one of
course now Bishop d7 Black is preparing
to play b5 and he's looking forward on
attacking my king and create counter
play a very difficult move now you need
to find well let's think about it first
before we raise our hand because I had
to spend five to ten minutes on this
wall sir and I certainly don't want you
to guess my moves I want you to
understand the ideas so you can apply in
your own games some of this ideas he is
threatening to play b5 + h5 the problem
with this move then you actually lose
your bishop and then he would take take
any play h6 you go back maybe one maybe
even just f6 it's not easy to break
through here block would be a very very
solid here so it should be seven so what
is that movement that I played here huh
it works perfect for both ideas it works
perfect because I want to also play h5
and I also want to be ready when he
plays b5
if you just develop your bishop then he
just goes b5 so if you just pick up he
just goes p5 that's that that's the idea
okay yes
Knight p3 we lose the bishop strong
bishop you lose we don't want to lose
the bishop here my dark square bishop is
very important here that's why I have
advantage so don't want to lose the
bishop yes uh-huh
why do you like it very good very good
this should be three and now I'm ready
to play h5 h6 and if he plays b5 don't
rush another very strong move needed
here if you place now another very very
strong move you have d5 okay
93 Bishop c6 position gets a little bit
loose when you play e5 little bit loose
I certainly thought about h5 I certainly
thought about h5 but I thought it could
do maybe it's you know some h6 ideas
then some 96 he has still see my queen
is it looks good my queen but it's just
it's not the best square for my queen
actually here because the Queen is there
blocking the rook and it's also standing
on this tempest all the time 96 93 so
you gotta watch out for that night jump
a lot so you want to make a move and put
your Queen on a stable square so then he
doesn't have this Knight jumps anymore
so which square I'm talking about here
aha well let's be a little more specific
yeah
c3 yes c3 absolutely you put the Queen
on c3 and now I have a positional threat
Bishop takes c5 he takes back so let's
say he takes Bishop takes c5 he takes
back Bishop c4 and White has a big
advantage here because black pawns are
very weak and in the endgame he can lose
the spawns and I'm ready actually to
advance my H 5 and G five pawns okay
so that's why so I play Quincy tree and
now he plays Knight to b3 I don't think
he should have done this maybe she
should have gone only six but and by the
way who can tell me why for example he
cannot do this tactics like 94 why this
doesn't work because I had to make sure
I had to make sure that this doesn't
work because if it works then I will be
regretting it yes very good
takes yeah you always have to think
about tactics and now discovery check
wins the Queen if I didn't have this my
strategy would fail excellent now and
why for example he cannot play this move
I like we should take c5 accurate takes
that's it see connecting the rooks now
piece up white is piece up
so he goes Knight to b3 here tonight
actually looks you know in chess
sometimes you have dispositions where
the piece just looks good but if you
start thinking about a little bit deeper
then you realize it's not really doing
anything here so the knight looks kind
of threatening you know there on v3 and
you may think wow this Knight is there
but in reality is not doing anything and
now he left his King exposed and now
it's time to go for the decisive attack
here and finish this game within a few
moves within few moves
h5 that was our idea and whenever you
have some good ideas you stick with that
idea I had to pass that idea for a
little bit to make sure I neutralized
what he's doing and now after the
neutralization it's time to continue
with the same plan ready to play h6 now
and try to checkmate him on the dark
squares now if he plays h6 you play g5
he takes h6 takes rook h6 decisive if he
takes take take tactics threatening
Bishop h6 check and f6 this week bishops
are just too strong for him in this
position so this point he realized
things are looking pretty bad for him
here so he paid f6 trying to at least to
shut down my Queenie then I have to be
precise here because one more movie
plays h6 then it's going to be much
harder to break that position because he
will be solidly protein I'm still much
better no question about it but it will
be harder to break through and I would
like to make sure that I get the more
stay out of it so which move you should
try to play to get that strength here g5
F takes G five not so clear yeah yes
H 6 again staying with the same idea
right when you went a pound which is on
H 5 he doesn't want to stay there he
wants to reach on H 6 now we are ready
to take and expose the position of the
king here and if you place g 5 you see
the tactic right they should take 3 5
takes Queen g7 checkmate so he plays G 6
and now what do we call upon like this
when the pawn is on a six-string what we
call that then it's a big plus for you
to have a pawn like this in an endgame
is good in a middle game positions with
the Queens on the board what do we call
that I've mentioned that in my previous
lectures if you watch them very
important to know this because you
should remember an aim to get a pawn
like this on a sixth rank yes we'll get
to that but the name for that is a pawn
wedge so remember that sometimes they
refer wedge pawn pawn wedge very strong
in this position okay so remember trying
to get the pawn wedge if you're white on
a sixth rank if you're black on a third
drunk this will help you with a lot of
tactics so what's the best move here g5
is a possibility but G father I thought
he can play maybe Queenie five maybe and
Here Come b5
correct now the problem is if he takes
and now you see the strength of edge
pond because if it takes you see that
that's why you want to have a pawn wedge
like that okay on g7 on h6 so I took and
now he played rook f7
let's think about it a little bit you
know you don't want to take chances
right so we need to spend a little bit
of time here position is already winning
here but absolutely when you have a
piece that is not developed even if
you're winning what you should do
develop it develop your pieces remember
even in the winning positions
you should remember about that
development right because it would be
harder for me to win this game without
my Bishop and rook but if I get those
pieces in then his position that can be
defendable so Bishop c4 Bishop e6 and
very strong move don't rush don't rush
it you know when a plant offering
exchange you don't just want to think
about taking all the time you want to
think about should I change should I
maybe keep the tension should I find a
way to break through and get in with my
pieces at this point you have a better
position and extra pawn and also
blocking is quite weak so what would be
the strongest move here to try to break
through
yes
but pawn the rook is protecting it yeah
if the rook wasn't there would have been
a good idea but the rook is protecting
it
absolutely absolutely b6 good job the
reason is the b5 pawn is it's an extra
pawn but it's a little bit weak and one
day I could lose that pawn so what I'm
doing I'm giving this pawn but breaking
that pawn chain here and winning a
really good pot on d6 and not only that
my rook is coming coming in into his
territory
so b6 he takes rook t6 he takes when I
pass b5 attacking my queen here what
should I do now
I have few options here but I need to
find I truly need to find the best
square now for my queen what square is
that okay well let's see Queen D Phi was
played because it's a centralization
right
okay well Knight a5 was played my
opponent finally realized last hand
moves this Knight was sitting there on
b3 but I wasn't doing that much and my
bishop is basically calling this Knight
off because taking away all the squares
so just really cutting the squares off
for this knife so he goes Knight goes
back on a5 now nine goes back on a5 now
and what to do here if you remember what
I just said earlier you will find the
best move here there are a few ways to
win here but what's the best and the
most technical way to win this game
technique yeah
Bishop d4 you could do that but what
else
excellent excellent
see everybody should remember about
development I just mentioned that when
you're winning what do you do still
develop your pieces see you're attacking
but let's bring one more attacker in
then we have everybody in and then it
would be easier to win so remember that
group goes to d1
I could I could yes I could do that too
yes that's good but I have something
even better than that what you saying
it's good but that's just gonna be an
end game where I'm just winning but
still a little bit technical so
obviously it goes 94 because that's the
purpose of the night so now I put the
night here why to play find a move that
is gonna force the resignation here he
just resigned I made a move and left and
okay I didn't expect him to resign but
they just calculated for two three
minutes and realized he is just losing
like a rock maybe or getting made it
here think about it raise your hand
first let's think about her first
that's a quintic look is just an end
game yeah it's good but I don't
necessarily want to play an end game
here if I can just win the game yeah
this is winning position but it's it's
still we play for another hour or so at
least
yes in the back
when here or when okay you mean here
no but here when he plays 94 he's
attacking too many things here see so he
kind of [ __ ] me so he maybe that I
just [ __ ] them but that's why I don't
have time for g5 yet yes
93 and now he is attacking me yeah it
takes only treant attacking me oh sure
excellent that's the winning move rook
is six strong move rookie six attacking
the Queen now let's see why he resigned
why this strong international master
resigned okay the problem is now this
rook is hanging in a lot of lines so he
has one two three moves right anything
else just loses it you know so if he
goes to see it mb8 what do we do no tax
of six threatening threatening here okay
now he goes here we could take this but
let's check made check and mate and
again see that mating net is here
because of that town wager on h6 so now
so if the Queen moves away it's clear we
just take on f6 and we just made him
just gonna get made it if he goes to a
fade now Bishop c5 comes in with the
tempo tempo we talked about that earlier
right
always look for those temples developing
and attacking temples now he takes here
down rook
so just if it goes away take on a 6 and
itself so that doesn't ok and the last
line is 90 X III that I had to calculate
I spend a couple of minutes just
checking the lines and then play through
key six now what's the winning line here
excellent now attacking the loose piece
yeah that's a loose piece so he takes
check he goes back here and again do you
see how important role this pawn is
playing here in the game in all these
lines it's causing blacks so much
problems here so many problems here so
you have to look for this ideas when you
look at grandmasters games a lot of
times they start pushing that H pawn and
you may think why is he really doing
this it doesn't look like he's
threatening anything but in the future
they anticipate you know it would be
useful to have the pawn advance in end
games as well a lot of end games is
useful for you to have a pawn advance
some positions also you have to be
careful not to lose the punt but overall
it's it's a big plus okay okay so he
resigned here any any questions you have
about this game very good now I will set
up a one position for you and see if you
can find the right plan here okay white
to play and you need to find the best
continuation for white first you need to
analyze this position and understand
what you're playing for in chess during
the game you should kind of try to
always evaluate the position objectively
not just think oh I'm playing white I
should always win no you have to always
be objective and know what you're
playing for then it will help you to
make right decisions so in this position
first thing you need to think what you
playing for so let's spend a few minutes
to understand just why this trying to
draw
correct now we come to the second
question how okay well interesting do
you have a plan or is it just a move
okay let me test you then see 3 KD 8
just yeah you only call when I ask you
then you can tell the answer
when you reach this end games you
actually need to calculate it out okay
because you can make a move and then
start calculate because maybe that move
you made was already losing so you
always calculate it out so basically
here it's an end game not too many
pieces on the board you need to
calculate here and all the way until the
draw here okay you ready okay we have c3
suggestion uh-huh
impressive
very good stalemate see you have to
think about this ideas so you calculate
it out you start out with c3 you you
just need to realize that if you play c4
right away you lose because when you
play here it was King it and he's gonna
win this that's why we need to get this
position with his move so he can go key
d8 and so the block our King and when
the King is blocked then we can do the
stalemate idea so that's why we play the
c3 and blocking cannot go away because
he will lose this seven if you play C 5
we just take it and it's a stalemate so
remember that you must calculate 4 or 5
moves in advance in n games
ok ok next position I have
black to play here and what worried what
he should try to do here what is black
trying to do here is he playing for the
wing or is it playing for @oh first you
whenever you trying to solve a puzzle
analyze the position you always try to
see what you're really trying to do here
yes what are we trying to do here draw
make sense because we're down upon his
pawn is on a seven trunk he's got
another pass pawn that is coming down
the line and so we're trying to draw
this correct next question now how we do
that okay let's just go a little bit
slower so everyone here can follow and
we can understand okay
so King g3 now your threat is to play
rook a one mate
so if he doesn't play the correct move
he's gonna get made so it was rook G a
check King h3 now
if I Queen rook a one check he is
sacrificing the rook as well and if
takes still mate
he's sacrificing and now it leads to a
checkmate still made here with all this
extra material white cannot win okay
what else he can do the threat is is
huge and actually actually you also want
to take this that's your main idea to
win this pawn if he goes back here now
you no longer interested in taking this
pawn because you have made so he is
gonna try to do Luke g2 and see if he
can still try to win this what do you do
that
check and we take the pun
absolutely and the final idea he goes
King to g1 trying to escape from - we
could take the pawn that's probably
still a draw but now who can find the
elegant way to make a draw here
immediately immediately forcing the draw
here okay where Luke G to check if the
King moves away black actually wins
because he takes it protects the a H
square he can't do anything so now he
takes and it's still made so always
remember about the stalemate idea okay
thank you everyone for coming to this
lecture and tomorrow we have more
lectures okay bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]